what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to a
tick tock compilation
about a time when you realize the bar
was super low for men before i start
do not forget to subscribe subscribe to
the channel i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers and each and every one of
you
helps while you're at it bring that
notification bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
okay time when you realize that the bar
is super low for matt
i was less than 24 hours
out from having my c-section with my son
the hospital was room in baby rooms in
with you
i was up all night holding him and
feeding him um because he would not lay
in the bassinet
so well i was up with him while my
now ex-husband slept on the couch beside
me the whole night
the lights were dim in the morning when
my doctor came to check on my incision
and i said go ahead and turn the lights
on
and he said no let's let him sleep
i have my cell phone and i can use the
flashlight on my cell phone so
my doctor checked my c-section
incision with the flashlight on his cell
phone
as to let my husband continue sleeping
tell me about the time
damn oh my god that's kind of
that's that's bogus that's that's i'm
not even gonna lie to you guys that's
bogus that the bar is super low for men
so one time i got rejected by this girl
after our first date like i thought it
went well but
apparently it didn't because she told me
you know after i asked her when she was
free again she said like you know she
wasn't into it
and um she just wasn't sure if she
wanted to see him again
no worries so i text her like hey not a
problem um
i get it if you change your mind let me
know you have my number but if not good
luck out there
and i figured that'd be the end of it um
and then like a week or two later no
contact she hits me up and i get a
second date
awesome um so we go out and i figured
i'd do better this time but
it was bad oh she should he should not
have accepted a second date
with her he should not have taken her
she clearly wasn't into him
the obvious that i wasn't gonna get a
third date out of this um
so towards the end i just decided to ask
her like what
like why did i get the second date if
you knew this wasn't for you
and she should have told me that it was
because of the way i handled the
rejection after the first date
like i didn't freak out i didn't call
her like a [ __ ] or anything like
simply because i was able to take a no
for an answer
like we have to do better guys tell me
okay i will say that handling rejection
with grace is very attractive but
bro you should not have taken her out
again you should not have
about the time when you shouldn't have
said like oh i got a second date yay
like she told you no and then changed
her mind later
because you showed that you were fine
without her you that
you shouldn't have accepted that i
realized that the bar is super low for
men
i was at the club with my friends and we
were dancing having fun and this guy
came up to me
okay what type of guys are you gonna
find at a club
i'm just saying i don't think that's
representative of men like men you find
in a club
looking i was looking at you and i
thought you were so pretty and
i just wanted to come over here and say
that and like
do you want to like kiss a little bit oh
that's
weird that is that's not a good line i
don't because
i'm here with my friends and i'm just
having fun
i'm not interested and say oh that's all
right then
sorry for bothering you and he turned
around and walked away
i have never found someone more
attractive in my entire life
and i said to my friends that's kind of
what the manosphere preaches
to walk away like be okay
i almost want to go after him and kiss
him
because he was damn
when i tell you the bar is way down in
hell
yeah but they're they're the guys that
you choose
not kidding not kidding
tell me about the time when you realize
that the bar is super low for men
i'm going to tell you how easy it is to
get a female to like you in college
if a girl is interested in you enough to
come to your room and chill with you
this is all you got to do when she comes
to your room
invite her to sit on the bed you pull
out a chair
and sit in that [ __ ] do not go
near her
do not touch her just talk with her
chill and vibe the entire time do this
the first
and maybe the second time y'all hang out
and she'll be so
shocked and impressed that you weren't
just trying to [ __ ]
that she gonna attack you next time
y'all hang out mark my words
tell me about the time when you
hmm interesting i realize that the bar
is super low for men
so there's this nail polish that you can
buy i really like the lighting here
and basically you stick your finger in
your drink and it will basically light
up a certain color
or alert you somehow um if your drink
has been spiked
here it is if you want it it's called
undercover colors
tell me about the time when you it's a
good idea actually that's a really good
idea i realize that the bar is super low
for men
mine was last year mine was when i was
telling my current boyfriend
two months into dating that i just ate a
ten piece of chicken nuggets that he had
seen and i was like
i kind of want just a bite of a
hamburger and he's like
you don't have to tell me what you're
eating
like eat whatever you want and i was
like wait really
like but i had 10 nuggets he's like okay
do you guys date people that care what
you eat
that has never happened to me um this
has been every relationship where people
literally
count my food or be like oh you're gonna
have two meals in one
it's just nuggets and a burger this one
it's my ex-boyfriend literally counting
the amount of chicken nuggets i had and
telling me he thinks it's time
for my stomach to stop
yeah and i thought it was completely
normal because i was fat i should
count my food and tell me what i'm full
tell me i've never dated something like
that but
i don't know i think like people are
allowed to have standard like health
standards if the if that's what they
want that's not important to every guy
but it's kind of weird if he's counting
your food about the time when you
realize that the bar is super low for
men
when i transitioned and started passing
i got complimented for the dumbest crap
like
oh he doesn't smell like farts he must
be a hygiene king his shirt doesn't have
stains or holes in it
he's a fashion icon he got a 20 haircut
every three months
he takes such good care of himself he's
never sent to you up text
he's a genius he must be a god like the
bar is so low
tell me about the time when you realize
that the bar is super low for men
i'm gonna go with the time that a tick
tock about my vasectomy consultation
went viral
and half of the comments were people
crucifying my wife because she didn't
have a tubal ligation
i've watched four children come out of
that woman
if you've seen that if you've watched it
up close
and you think that that person owes you
anything in this life
after that
you're wrong i have no opinion on that i
have none
whatever you want to do tell me about
the time when you realize that the bar
is super low for men
when i started dating my current
boyfriend he asked me what kind of
flowers i liked what were my favorite if
i liked receiving them
i said yeah i guess i don't really know
though i've only even given them one
time
when my ex cheated on me tell me about
the damn
yeah personally for me i don't really
care about flowers like that's not
something that's super important to me
but
damn damn that's awkward time when you
realize
i don't even know why i'm like watching
this video because
all these stories are super like bad so
i don't even know
what to say
okay so this happened about a year ago
and
i just matched with this girl off tinder
we talk and talk for like two weeks
until she says
hey i want to come pick you up for food
i say cool keep in mind this was when i
wasn't as
extroverted as i am now so like i just
thought we were just going to hang out
get some food talk for a little bit and
then take me back home
as soon as i get in the car she says hey
do you want to play some music
i said oh yeah sure i have a personal
playlist that i [ __ ] love
i've made over time it's whatever
the first song i put it on shuffle and
the first song that plays is
treat people with kindness by harry
styles it just came out
and she looks at me and she says you
know this song like you like this song i
said yeah i [ __ ] love the song
she says okay i can see us having sex
tonight what
that's it that's all it took
tell me about the time when you realize
that the bar is super low for matt
my my criteria for a guy
has to be that he has to wash his dishes
because my ex didn't wash his dishes he
just
hit them under the bed oh my gosh ew
ew that's so gross tell me about the
time when you realize that the bar is
super low for men it's not even time
it's
times it's just everyone posts the bare
minimum like
oh my god especially with couples
posting each other you know
yes it's cute of course i love that [ __ ]
i hate the fact that girls
find it so rare for that to happen the
last talking stage i was in
i was posting her in the talking stage
like constantly
because i'm big on publication because i
want everyone to know
that that's my girl you know that's
that's [ __ ] my that's mine like when
girls say oh he doesn't lag
oh my god he opened the door for me
first he bought me flowers
complimented me so much today he said
that he was sorry
he actually showed his face on facetime
actually shows his face on snapchat
they should have been doing that in the
first place obviously i love it when
people get appreciated
but i don't see it as often as it's
supposed to be this is why i don't date
anyone
because it's way too easy i can date
someone right now if i wanted to
but i have standards and i don't have
fast anything
don't take anything but 100 only about
the time when you realize that the bar
is super low for men
do you guys oh shoot do you guys think
that stuff is like important
um what he was talking about with like
the public stuff mine was last week when
i was telling my best friend about the
phone date that i just had
and i said it was good because he had
good turn-taking skills
taking skills uh
see this is interesting because you can
see a little bit more about like
i don't know girl's side to all of this
and i think a lot of times in the manner
sphere like
everyone makes it seem as if
you know it's women's own fault for a
lot of situations they're in and
that's totally true i agree with that
but
you know sometimes people go through
stuff so let me know in the comments if
you guys agree
or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification bell i'll talk to you guys
next time